hey everybody it's mike from overflows
and in this quick video i'm going to
talk about some of the highlights that i
saw in the overflow over april 18 and
april 19th and i'll be talking about
specifically the e-mini the es market
and looking at a one-minute chart you
know a lot of people ask me mike why do
you look at a one-minute chart well you
know what that's what uh the majority of
traders that are especially when they're
new to trading will start to look at
they'll start looking at time-based
charts now this is your pretty much your
basic footprint chart right which shows
you the bid offer volume um as well as
the point of control and the delta at
the bottom now
when most people uh come into order flow
you know this is what they're looking at
and you know while this is a good tool
you can find some interesting things uh
happening in the order flow so for
example this is yesterday this is uh
april 18th this is around 9
45 in the morning you know we had just
popped up about 9 26 9 27 we made these
little new highs at 44.03
uh and a half 4403 and three quarters
started to come off a little bit and
kept testing that high up here you can
see we tested it again at 9 41. um then
we got within
one tick of the high again at 9 44 and
again at
9 46. now what was interesting about
this high of the day that's what this
green line
comes along at the top now there's a if
you're not
really comfortable with using um
ninjatrader eight
you know they do provide some free tools
and one of the tools that i like to use
is a free ninjatrader tool um it's
called current open day high low close
you just scroll down
and you'll find it in here says current
day open high low it's a good reference
point you know the
high and the low of the day obviously is
a good intraday reference point then if
you're an intraday trader you know you
need to know where that is so it's good
just to have that line drawn up there so
as we're coming up here testing these
highs we hit it test it once twice a
third time now
what was interesting when we're up here
at this high
now normally you're at the highs right
you if you're going to expect the market
to go higher and keep going higher and
higher um you're going to be looking for
aggressive buying right and the the
clearest sign of aggressive buying in
the market is positive delta delta is
the net difference between the
aggressive buyers and the aggressive
sellers if delta is positive means
aggressive buyers
were in control of that bar if the delta
in the bar is negative that means the
aggressive sellers were in control okay
so we're up here at this high we hit the
high hit a new high we got negative
delta first time it's negative 72 then
the next time it's negative 118. that's
not a good sign of a strong high right
because when you hit that high you got
selling coming in okay then it comes off
a little bit you know it comes off from
4 400 down to what is that about 96 95
and just sort of goes sideways comes
back up
gets hits that high again this time we
got positive delta of 224 the bar right
before it was positive delta as well 177
okay
so we're seeing some signs here we got
some positive delta coming in and then
we just go sideways we don't take out
the high we come off and we just sort of
go sideways with some positive delta uh
134 234 okay
it's not you know small it's not
negative you know right now it's still
positive so you know maybe this market
can take out the high
come up here within a tick of the high
and we've got negative delta
okay so we're making a run back up at
the high but sellers are coming in the
aggressive sellers are coming in this
time
market comes off a little bit we got
negative delta the bar you know it
starts trading down but then it comes
back up so it did have some buying lathe
in the bar um not enough to turn it
positive
and then we get this next bar here at
946 where we come up again within one
tick of the high and we got positive
delta but the market just reverses and
closes down it's a red candle a red
candle with positive delta
is
what do you think is going to happen
right you see the positive delta you
think well there's aggressive buying we
should go higher but actually what's
happening is supply is now coming into
the market
okay we've seen buying and balance here
47 against zero uh 88 against zero
obviously got the 206 against 41 here
this is what's causing this positive
delta right in here because as this
market starts trading back up towards
the high there's supply in the market
there's passive sellers offering it out
up here to uh willing aggressive buyers
thinking that this market's going to
break out and go higher
well it doesn't right and those buyers
this is the
we have the high here so this is the
second third this is the fourth time
we're making an attempt at that high
and
people are just tired right traders
they're running out of bullets so to
speak to take this market higher and it
doesn't go anywhere right and the market
eventually sells off from there so sort
of one of the the signs was early when
we first hit that high you had that
negative delta strong negative delta
then you just sort of going sideways
with mostly negative deltas some
positives coming in here
the negative negative and then i get
that last burst of aggressive buying
coming in here but it's met with supply
in the market it's met with strong
offers right
strong passive sellers that are there
just you know
they're happy to sell up here because
they're anticipating the market to go
down right and usually you know people
talk about smart money and dumb money
this is the smart money up here right
they they they got a lot of supply
they're holding a lot of contracts
they're happy to offer it out up here
right maybe they bought from lower you
know below 43.90 or or even much lower
and as the market's trading up here you
know they think the run is over so
they're happy to offer it out up here
for all those willing buyers and once
the buyers that are buying the heck out
of it trying to get it to go higher
realize they can't they start selling
right that's why this bar reverses very
quick okay then the market sort of goes
sideways and
you know starts heading down right goes
it drops from that 44 double o area you
know the 10 point drop down to 43.90
where there was a strong bid here you
see 11 30 traded on the bid
right at the low of this bar now this
yellow line is the um opening price of
the session but you know that that was
its target right it's a nice 10-point
move down
now
you know if you remember yesterday right
i mean we sold off quite nicely
uh then going into the close we had that
very very strong um rally you know
basically after about what was at about
2 30
um
240-ish right here actually 250-ish i
mean we're selling off from
this nice move down from 80 down into
the 60s we'll get down here
at 251
and get this nice reversal bar and the
market shot right back up right back up
above 4 400. so it made this nice
beautiful move from
you know below 4370 up to 4400
and it happened
very quickly happened in about 15
minutes and
what were the signs in the order flow
well
there was a number of signs actually
if you know what to look for okay so
you can sort of see some of the buying
coming in here because remember right we
had been selling off you know and
selling off quite dramatically you see
all this red right this is all negative
delta okay you're seeing small positive
deltas you know 39
67 60 53 85. so
whatever little buying that you had in
there just really wasn't much it was
just getting run over by the aggressive
sellers you know 500 600 875 400
and we started hitting these little
pockets in here you know some nice
positive delta 250 900 500 but then
there's still a bit more selling comes
in minus 100 markets drops down to this
area here at 1451. now again if you're
just looking at a normal footprint chart
okay
if you're an experienced trader you can
start to see some of these things right
this was a prominent point of control
you're starting to see multiple buying
imbalances come in
and this area why did the market come
back to this area down here right you
know 65 why didn't it come down to 63 60
you know even down here to 61 or 60 or
something well
this is where
understanding
certain things in the order flow is
going to come in handy now you know i
have my order flows trader software you
know i started this video because i just
want to show you some of the basic stuff
on order flow but when you start looking
at
you know some of the advanced things of
order flow things such as you know
prominent points of control so let me
turn them on
okay prominent point of control
prominent point of control
um i'll turn on uh what is this
the value areas so you can see this is
the bar value area
okay and i'll turn on the
imbalances right the multiple imbalances
meaning
you know
buying and balances you know several
buying and balances in a bar or several
um
selling it balances in a bar okay so let
me just add that on uh give this chart a
second to
up here let me just get something to
drink real quick
okay coming up here give it a second
where is my
cursor
okay boom all right so
you see it's
now we're seeing
a different picture okay we're seeing
the value area in the bar here okay
we're seeing
the primary point of control it's
highlighted here okay it's got this
um
was a cyan color for the point of
control as opposed to just your normal
black you're seeing this pink box around
it's actually a magenta box those tell
me there's multiple buying imbalances
okay so how does this little rally
differ from this rally here okay so
because here you got the positive delta
right two nine 252 927 541
here you got
negative 564 okay
and then positive 570 positive 1109
positive 821 and this was the one that
rallied right this one it just sort of
fell over again
well here you've only got one two
imbalances here one in balance here you
don't have one imbalance here okay so
you got the positive delta you don't
really have much else
point of control is not really giving
you much of information just your normal
point of control sort of appearing you
know sort of in the middle of the bars
this one here has this nice prominent
point of control
sticking out
okay
and you got this magenta box around
there it's telling you that you have
aggressive buying in the bar
and coming in at three or more levels
one two three right here it's not a
stack buying and balance right a lot of
traders like to look for stacked buying
imbalances this is not a stack buying
and balance this is just mine and
balances that are spread out in the bar
and you have this level right to see
this green
zone being drawn out here between 43 60
43 64 and three quarters this was an
area this was a reference area generated
from earlier around 11 o'clock let's
just scroll back
okay this was a value area here
that was important right that's why it's
being drawn out right even in this bar
here you got this nice little rally
you've got this
bullish prominent point of control right
here and it's drawing out this zone here
4366 to 64 three quarters it's an area
we're looking for if the market comes
back to it
it might hold if the order flow
you know shows some signs of it holding
and what happened it came right back
into that area literally right carbon
copy right into that zone from 65 to 66
this zone is drawn from 66 to 64 in
three quarters and it that's where the
rally started so
you know trying to buy this little
bounce here with the nice positive
deltas that's just not enough to go on
but when you start adding in
the positive deltas here and this one
does have a negative delta but why
because you have support here right this
1574 on the bid side right at this area
of 43 65 and a half there was buyers
that came into the market
passive buyers to support this market
this was their level
okay and you can see it and that's why
you have the negative delta 564 because
the aggressive seller's thinking this
market's still going down
right they're selling it but there's
someone there just happy to absorb all
that selling
okay that's why you got the negative
delta so that's why i'm not panicking
it's oh negative delta minus 500 i
should be looking to get short well no
why is it negative is because you have
people coming in there absorbing
that selling
okay then the market rallied up rallied
up nice
30 points right from that and you know
this is on a one-minute chart you know i
know a lot of people say oh you can't
trade a one-minute chart um well
you know sometimes if you're looking at
a five-minute chart a 15-minute chart
you're missing
you're missing that my new detail that's
going to give you the clue of a move
that's about to start or a market that's
turning so you're seeing a lot of
information in here of a market getting
ready to turn
and it turned it made that nice move
okay so you know let's talk about today
april 19th again there was a couple
interesting things
as well um
today and again again it happened right
around the close as well so let me just
go back to that time
[Music]
where is it here now this time we were
coming off
we had just made new highs late in the
session
okay we made this high here at uh
what was that 2
made this high it was at 65 and three
quarters
then we made this high up here at 67
and then the market dropped okay
um it
doesn't look like much of a drop but you
got one bar that's dropping from you
know 60 and a quarter down to you know
48 and three quarters so that's over a
10 point drop in this one bar and
obviously the next bar uh very similar
about nine points
but what were
the signs here okay well
look as we're coming up into the high
okay
this first high actually when i saw this
i thought this market was just going to
fall over didn't it rallied up made that
new high but it started to fall over
because why right we're coming up here
we're making these new highs and the
deltas you know they're still positive
but it got interesting it was 208 389
668.
then right after the high it's still
positive but 191 and 3
negative 68 so it was going
and you know it was making that what you
would expect to happen as you're making
that high but once you made that high
the vine just dried up i mean it was
still aggressive buying is 191 and 3
which is nothing but
the price action in this bar is down and
what you would want to see ideally is
you know a green candle or
you know something not really indicative
of a market that's ready to drop then
you see the next candle right i mean
honestly this one candle by itself
probably not enough to go on thinking
this mark is going to drop but then when
you get that next candle i mean this
positive delta of three might as well be
minus 300 for all intents and purposes
um you're seeing that exhaustion print
in there as well
but you just see the delta it's not
behaving the way you'd want to see it
for a market that you're expecting to
make a new high right away i mean
eventually you know the market did sell
off again it doesn't look like much but
you're talking to selloff from about 60
down this 55 then it rallied again now
you see something very similar okay boom
you make the new high or the bar right
before the new high positive delta 1000
new high positive delta 1300 great
we're going to keep going up right just
like yesterday we had that monster rally
going into the close now we're going
into the cash close
but
where's the buying it's gone you see
positive delta of 126. it's not what you
want to see for a market that's going to
be going higher just as here it was
positive delta of 191
but again you'd want to see it a little
bit stronger okay but again that one bar
by itself
just like this one bar by itself not
enough to go off of wait for the next
bar okay then next bar
39 delta now this bar was interesting
because earlier in that bar there's very
strong selling it was minus 726 it
actually closed up positive at 7 39 and
normally i'd find that bullish
but where it's happening it's happening
at the height of the day
you know i'm always a bit hesitant of
buying like that that can't go any
higher
and again you know you're seeing the
delta shrinking 1300 126 39 that's not
the the sequence you want to see you
want to see
you know 1300 maybe 500 you know at
least three or four hundred here instead
you're seeing the market
the aggressive selling coming in and
then boom the bottom just drops out
right here minus thirteen hundred you
just made the high and you're getting
very strong selling coming in here
again market drops here comes back up
makes that attempt to come back up it's
testing this
zone here this value area zone
and just trades right into it and then
it drops back down from you know 60 down
into the 40s um going into the close
now
again i don't get too much into it but
you know that's how using delta using
point of controls using imbalances can
sort of give you an insight into the
market so
hopefully you found this video useful
so if you've enjoyed this video be sure
to hit the like button if you want to
see more like this be sure to click
subscribe you know i'm trying to post
more and more videos up there for you
guys
and obviously you know the more you like
them the more positive feedback i get
the more
i'll be posting so thanks everyone
bye-bye